quite nicely as I retired I actually
thought it was just a young man's game
because I remember jumping on red-eyes
three or four times a month and not
hesitating flying across the US a kind
of London or Tokyo see a customer and
just by telling him oh I happened to be
in town just to get the meeting and as I
got older my body just physically
wouldn't let me do that but surprisingly
I now teach and have taught the National
Science Foundation innovation core which
is my coursework at Stanford and found
that the average age of the principal
investigators average age was 45 years
old and surprisingly we got them to move
as fast or faster than entrepreneurs
maybe not on a continuous basis but what
they brought to the game was experience
and so I kind of find that there really
is an interesting trade-off between you
know young and too dumb to know it can't
be done an enormous energy versus wise
entrepreneurs who are still passionate
and still willing to try new things but
could say you know let's kind of like
bound the box because we know these are
going to be time wasters and other than
the physical energy I kind of find that
if you're passionate and you're a type a
entrepreneur just never goes away